by the Administration has done
everything it can for two years to stoke
a third world war beginning in Eastern
Europe and that plan is unfolding before
our eyes and no one seems to notice
zelenski the president of Ukraine the
despot who runs Ukraine was unseen and
last night and he said he expects the
bite Administration to give him F-16
soon
we don't have the fights a chance to to
deal with it
to counteract the Russian hits and we
really need this and uh really appeal to
the president that they could start
training Ukrainian pilots and the
President Biden told me that it would be
worked upon and uh I believe that uh
United States will give us the
opportunity to defend and defend our
skies
haven't they been telling us for over a
year that Russia is about to be defeated
then why are we sending an ever
increasing amount of money and material
to Ukraine could they be lying to us and
speaking of lying to us remember they
told us that Russia blew up its own
pipeline the New York Times tools
everyone told us that shut up Putin
Defender the Russians did it well now
they're admitting the Russians didn't do
it but we didn't do it either something
called a pro-ukrainian group blew up the
Nordstrom Pipeline and created the
largest environmental disaster in human
history and also shafted our NATO allies
in Western Europe a pro-ukrainian group
okay Dulce gabbard served in the
congressman for president she joins us
tonight congresswoman thanks so much for
coming on so this is a pro-ukrainian
group that has the military prowess to
blow up one of the world's most
important pipelines but we had the by
demonstration had nothing to do with it
is that the new lie that they're telling
us
apparently so it is it is so obvious at
this point Tucker that the United States
and NATO are responsible for this act of
sabotage and active War attacking and
destroying this Nordstrom pipeline
they've been lying to us all along about
it now they've been busted and so
they're trying to sell us this absurd
cover-up story where on the one hand
they're telling us well we have this new
intelligence that shows us no Americans
or Brits were involved in this attack
but then at the same time we can't draw
any conclusions from the Intelligence on
who actually did it because we don't
have specific details on each of the
members of this so-called pro-ukrainian
group like it's just it's Insanity for
anybody who's paying attention to what
they're saying the reality is that they
are responsible for this and there are
short-term and long-term serious
implications for this action it sets
this precedent Tucker for countries like
Russia North Korea Iran and China to go
ahead and launch these attacks and
sabotage against critical infrastructure
against other countries is light gas
pipelines undersea cables Financial
systems satellites the list goes on and
on just imagine the kind of problems to
say the least that that would cause for
us the American people and for the world
well I'm just kind of just a super dumb
question no one's ever answered it so
this pipeline fed Germany which is the
economic engine of Europe Germany is the
key player in NATO we're all for NATO we
just wrecked the economy of our key NATO
Ally if Germany blew up the Hoover Dam
would they still be our tight NATO Ally
like does NATO have to disintegrate
after we get caught doing this
you know that's that's the thing here I
think a couple of points is the Biden
Administration NATO want us to believe
that that some that they want us to
believe this cover-up story first of all
which their cover-up story implies that
the United States and NATO's military
and intelligence agencies are so inept
and incapable that nobody knows what was
going on nobody saw this coming but
secondly you're exactly right this was
an act of War not just against Russia
but also against our Ally Germany also
an act of War can only be declared by
congress not by the president United
States or anybody else that clearly
didn't happen and that's where Biden
needs to address the nation tell us the
whole truth about what went down and
Congress needs to exercise its oversight
responsibilities to actually investigate
this to tell it to tell us the truth get
to the bottom of it and to hold those
responsible accountable yeah I mean it's
the craziest most Reckless thing I've
ever seen in 50 years of sort of paying
attention Tulsa thank you so much for
continuing to call attention it's just
unbelievable no one is paying attention
it really is it really is
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight